et si le corona virus devenait une
maladie saisonnière comme le rhume ou la
grippe
et si tous les ans ce virus venait
pendant l'hiver pour provoquer les
dégâts économiques et humains que nous
voyons aujourd'hui l'avenir du
coronavirus reste un grand mystère
peut-il muter pour devenir encore plus
dangereux ou au contraire disparaître à
tout jamais c'est ce que nous allons
voir aujourd'hui avec l'ami ma tarte
étudier les futurs possibles du virus et
vous allez voir ça peut être effrayant
en 2002 nous avons déjà connu le
coronavirus disons le il n'ya pas un
mais des coronavirus c'est pas la
première fois qu'il y à des infections
avec ce virus
ça commence dès les années 60 mais le
début d'une épidémie c'est en novembre
2002 avec le hasard ce kof
c'était pareil qu'aujourd'hui même folie
médiatique
sauf qu'elle a pu être stoppée par des
mesures d'isolement et de quarantaine
mais c'est pas fini
en juillet 2012 un nouveau cas de
coronavirus originaire du dromadaire
fait son apparition au qatar le maire ce
kof pour middle east river choice enjoy
celui là ne sera pas stoppée en même
temps il est très faiblement contagieux
le problème c'est que vous avez 38 % de
chances de mourir si vous la trappe et
comme on l'a vu ce n'est pas notre
première rencontre avec le coronavirus
et dans mes recherches ce qui m'a effaré
c'est qu'il n'existe aucun traitement
contre le sarce où le maire ce la seule
chose qu'on peut réussir à faire c'est
traiter les symptômes sur le virus de
2020 même si le nom change c'est 80% le
même virus que le sascoc de 2002 c'est
pour ça qu'on appelle le nouveau virus
le sascoc 2 mais là on dit pourquoi on
parle de kovy 10,9 et bien le co des dix
neuf c'est la maladie à ne pas confondre
avec le virus qui est le sascoc 2 comme
le vih et le virus qui provoque la
maladie le sida
on trouve ce coronavirus un peu partout
dans les shows seront avec la fameuse
soupe mais aussi et c'est la piste
privilégiée aujourd'hui celle du
pangolin car oui le corona virus est
partout dans la nature et à l'avenir si
nous continuons à être en contact avec
les animaux sauvages
ce genre de cas se reproduira
le coronavirus est il en train de muter
pour devenir plus dangereux mutation
c'est un mot qui fait peur
on imagine tout de suite resident evil
et ses monstres qui partent dans tous
les sens lorsqu'un virus se réplique
dans le corps des fois et il y à des
erreurs et ces erreurs sont une chance
pour le virus parce qu'elles peuvent
l'aider à être plus résistants à devenir
plus violents à mieux survivre
ces mutations sont extrêmement rares si
tu prends une personne les chances de
voir émerger une mutation dangereuse est
proche de zéro mais maintenant si tu
prends tes centaines de milliers de
personnes avec des millions de virus en
eux
là ça commence à devenir chaud et les
mutations ont commencé au brésil
on a observé des virus avec des génomes
très différent des échantillons chinois
la souche est ce plus anciennes généré à
owen en chine et la souche elle plus
agressive qui est une mutation de la
première une lutte darwinienne pour la
survie qui a créé ce monstre 70 % des
infections sont aujourd'hui de cette
souche les mutations ça veut aussi dire
des vaccins plus difficile à créer si le
virus s'installe sur le long terme ça ça
comme la grippe
tous les ans il faudra se faire vacciner
contre la souche en cours et plus le
virus se propagera plus il y aura des
mutations et plus il sera difficile
d'agir médicalement
sauf à limiter l'infection on aura pas
de vaccin miracle comme on l'a pour la
fièvre jaune ou la rougeole
demain toi qui ne te protège pas qui ne
lave pas les mains tu seras peut-être le
futur porteurs de la mutation qui
détruira l'humanité faut-il craindre ou
espérer
les vaccins contre la grippe existe
pourtant seule la moitié des gens se
vaccine et les résultats sont
dramatiques entre deux et six millions
de français touchés pour à peu près dix
mille morts chaque année oui 0,1 pour
cent de mortalité s'est déjà des
dizaines de milliers de vies eh bien le
coronavirus en italie ces 5 % de
mortalité
ça veut dire que si l'épidémie
s'installe comme une grippe ça serait
cinq cent mille personnes mortes chaque
année
donc non le couronne à virus n'est pas
une simple grippe mais ce qui fait peur
c'est pas sa mortalité sur doute
raisonnable
c'est sa croissance exponentielle
regardez si un malade contamine dix
personnes par jour premier jour malades
deuxième jour 121 au sixième jour on
approche déjà des deux millions dans la
réalité un infecté transmet en moyenne à
3 personnes
c'est suffisant pour que dans quelques
jours le million d' infecté soit le
virus en effet une particularité les
symptômes met beaucoup de temps à
arriver chez certains il n'y en a même
pas en fait là devant ton pc tu te sens
bien mais peut-être que tu est
contagieux et si 80 % des gens n'auront
qu'une petite grippe 20% requiert une
hospitalisation
si l'épidémie était total 20% de 60
millions de français
ça serait 10 millions de personnes or en
france la capacité des hôpitaux publics
n'est que de 200 mille lits si le nombre
de cas explose
il y aura un moment où il faudra choisir
à qui on donnera l'oxygène restants il y
aura un moment où les infirmières
surchargé s'effondreront de fatigue
il y aura un moment où les hôpitaux
seront pleins le taux de mortalité alors
va pas rester aussi bas mais
intéressons-nous à une statistique
sa longévité est ce que le coran navires
us tiendra pendant l'été
après tout tombent moins malades en été
les virus même de toute évidence pas les
temps estivaux et ça a l'air d'être le
cas
coville 19 se limite principalement à
l'hémisphère nord le virus se propage -
sur un axe nord-sud que sur un axe
est-ouest
parce qu'en ce moment c'est l'été dans
l'hémisphère sud et même s'il y a des
cas ils ne connaissent pas la même
propagation mais ne soufflait pas trop
vite
si l'été arrive chez nous dans l'autre
hémisphère ça sera l'hiver et le virus
ne va pas le gêner pour continuer son
travail
ça pourrait finir en effet boomerang du
sud vers le nord tous les six mois
le virus reviendrai heureusement la
recherche s'active le virus un scope 2
fait actuellement l'objet d'une
recherche intense et acharné la france
en lignes de front avec son célèbre
institut pasteur
mais il y en ad'autres 1 et partout dans
le monde on s'active
il suffit de se rendre sur le site pôle
med pour se rendre compte de
l'effervescence de la recherche autour
du coronavirus des dizaines d'essais
cliniques sont en cours par exemple avec
des molécules antivirales mais aussi
avec des patients précédemment affectés
ou même des cobayes volontaires
tout se passera bien oui tout se passera
bien si on est sérieux arrêtez de vous
moquer des gens un peu trop paranoïaque
carnot vous n'en faites pas trop si vous
vous laver les mains ou vous faites des
tchèques avec les coudes
ce petit délire riolo c'est juste une
crypte je continue à vivre
il met en danger toute l'humanité la
véritable menace n'est pas aujourd'hui
mais demain
vous n'avez pas peur du coronavirus
c'est très bien pour vous maintenant
arrêter de tuer des gens
car si vous survivrez sûrement virus
pensez à vos proches
pensez à vos grands parents j'espère que
vous allez a pris les choses
laquait abonnez-vous à la chaîne avec la
petite cloche du contenu scientifique de
qualité avec toute cette merveilleuse
team et y en aura merci beaucoup de nous
avoir suivis je vous dis à bientôt
ciao